so i absolutely love this movie i love
the way it kind of plays with the
question of what if because i think a
lot of us have kind of wondered that on
our own and i was wondering if that
question is kind of what attracted you
to the project i don't know if the
question itself attracted me to the
project i think it was more so
the
comfort at the end of the film that i
felt after i read the script feeling
like
there's a million different
paths that we have the opportunity to
take and there isn't
one right or wrong
path and i found that
inspiring and that was a story that i
wanted to tell because i feel like
sometimes in these maybe in these
multiverse there it's usually like a
dystopia one's like kind of dystopian
one's bad one's good but i liked how in
this story both lives
were good and were satisfying and
fulfilling and had love and and
friendship and family and that was
that was what was really special to me
what if we have always um
they do get my attention pretty
pretty like viscerally just because i
think there's
i look back on my life and there's so
many like anybody's life there's like
clear forks on the road
and i think in this one i love that it
did play with it into
like no matter what happen you're good
you'll be fine and
not fine it'll be great and i think that
in of itself just like
got my attention of like i guess
if i wouldn't be where i'm at right now
and the other possibility that i
sometimes i think i'm like i just got
lucky
when i think of the other version i'm
like who knows what
luck would have been on the other road
as well and like what that would have
been like and so i think that drew me
into it and then obviously
working with lily and lenary
two big draws
thank you so as much as you know the
ending is great for both natalie and
gabe um there is a moment where natalie
is kind of struggling to find her own
voice and gabe i think does struggle
with that too even if it's not directly
addressed so have the two of you ever
had that kind of moment where you felt
like your voice was getting lost and
kind of in the shuffle and everyone
else's it actually inspired me to write
and publish my poetry book swimming
lessons because
i felt at that point kind of creatively
a bit stunted like i wasn't in a
position where i could
where i wasn't really allowed to do what
i wanted creatively
and um and to be on in the show that i
was on i just sort of was playing this
character that i've been playing for a
while and i kind of just wanted to
stretch my wings a little bit but i
couldn't go and film something else i
couldn't i don't want to just drop an
album and become a singer so i was like
oh what can i do i can write a book i
can can i you know i can express this
other side of myself so that was sort of
a avenue that i took to release some
pent-up feelings and emotions
it's um it's beautiful thanks
although i will say i i don't have
regrets but i do
kind of regret publishing my poetry book
really yeah because i do feel that i
published it before i was ready
before it was ready before i was ready
and i feel that i'm a much better writer
now and i've written so much more and so
much better than from when i published
when's the new book dropping
there isn't no i thought about it but
i'm like it's so intimidating it's very
intimidating but well that's a whole
other um
when's it all been dropping
i've been i'm like no pipes um
yeah i think
there's it's sometimes um very like in
projects it's gotten lost within like
the shuffle of many people within it but
then it also
sometimes get lost it gets lost within
myself and then sometimes i'm my own
likes more silencer if you will of like
of stopping those or they're coming
creative thoughts and um follow through
of those so i think that's kind of one
that um
to comment on something outside of what
lily has talked about is
where i've um
struggled in some ways of like oh
you're an idiot you can't do that you
know so trying to like silence that
voice to like make sure that i'm
confident and grounded in the things
that i'm able to do
um that's kind of what i've been kind of
working through now and it's like it's
really exciting because like i think
once you take that one out you then
realize like oh in the space where other
people are also trying to silence you
that's works even less because if you're
not even listening to yourself like
there might be less effective
all right so to kind of wrap things up
on a lighter note what would you say is
your favorite scene in this movie
my favorite scene
i think it was one that's like finally
this is like yeah it's the biggest
build-up of every single scene like the
the the tension and the
and gabe's stress of like what he really
wanted and versus what was happening
to me was like
the moment that we had to throw down the
scene and then like at the end of it
wasn't like
yeah yeah i mean yeah i think that the
ending of both
of both relationships like them coming
back together is really beautiful when
it's jake who's you know left his job to
get a ticket to her show and
she's like
so surprised that he would do that for
her and and then obviously when gabe and
natalie have that moment on the bridge i
love that line when you say finally and
you have like a little glisten in your
eye it's so great it's like that is a
perfect rom-com moment
you